das ist die größe bei einem neugeborenen
ich muss sehr asketisch will ich muss
viel schlafen ich muss fit sein
naja längste ob die hier in leipzig sind
gute elf stunden
sie müssen richtig lust haben diese
mission und machen zu können sonst geht
das gar nicht
dort sind sie irgendwo schon mit tod
[Musik]
steht man ja immer davon aus dass man
erst mal ein gesundes baby hat haben nur
noch weil diagnostik gemacht und da hat
aber natürlich schon in der zehnten
woche gesehen irgendwas stimmt mit dem
herz nicht aber wird das alles klappt
deswegen es ist nicht selbst er
selbstverständlich
dann haben sie ähnliches glück im märz
machen sie das 34 jahre dann schaffen
sie die marke 10.000